a request for UKIP's group in the
European Parliament to return over half
a million pounds of funding looks like
being confirmed tomorrow the Alliance
for direct democracy in Europe the adde
which includes UKIP's 15m eps has been
accused of misusing european funds for
national campaigns on polling for you
keeping the 2015 general election and in
the brexit referendum this year well
Suzanne Evans is seeking to be the next
leader of u-kiss she joins me now from
central London very good morning to you
Suzanne Evans III I know you Kippur as
saying I'm doing anything wrong here but
if you're asked to repay the money will
you comply well obviously you know you
keep always says it's not like the other
political parties we're different and so
we need to be seen to be different as
well as you said you keep is denying
these allegations at the moment I'm not
a member of the European Parliament so I
have no connection with the adde so I
don't know what what exactly has
happened or not it's not something on my
own my remit as it were but if I become
leader in a few days time then
absolutely I want a full investigation
into this and I will say this too I
think that if there is shown to be
wrongdoing it should not be the party
that repays that money it should be
those people who were involved in that
wrongdoing or who gave authorisation to
such payments our members expect us to
operate at the top of the party fairly
equally and ethically and if it's been
shown that certain people haven't I'll
be very disturbed about that but you get
the irony of the the overall broader
point visa vu cap and the EU parliament
over the years I mean you've spent so
long producing it for overspending for
being wasteful with UK taxpayers money
and you know even if this money's been
used legitimately you Kipp has found
ways of getting almost as much money as
it can out of the EU in various ways
well you've got two separate issues
there yes the the way that you spend
taxpayers money is absolutely profligate
it's totally wrong and you keep has
quite rightly called that out on
numerous occasions and but as far as
actually spending money that we've been
given by the European Union legitimately
is concerned I absolutely stand by that
100% the British people have elected UK
penny peas there to go and do a job of
work in the European Parliament they
know they're not sending them there to
actually support the European
Union but they're sending us there to
challenge it and so that the money we
get back which of course is not a you
money it's British taxpayers money in
taxpayers money for other taxpayers
around the European Union it's perfectly
legitimate that we should have that
money and use it now to the leadership
now it's a said to put it I suppose
delicately Nigel Farage is not a fan of
Suzanne Evans therefore you have got a
chance of winning the leadership well
I've always said I'm a great fan of
Nigel and I was quite delighted to see
him crated in the papers this morning as
saying that if the the problems that
we've had in South cats at South South
Banat with the Conservative Party
allegedly spending far more money than
it should have done to fight that
campaign that he'd liked to if it comes
up for by-election he'd like to stand as
an MP there again and I'd be a hundred
percent behind that I'd be delighted to
see him fight that seat again why not so
as I say I don't really know what Nigel
thinks of me we haven't spoken for a
while but I'm a hundred percent behind
him and I hope he will continue to have
a fulsome role in the party going
forward whoever wins this leadership
election fulsome role in the party he
dominated doesn't it even if he left the
party in terms of the public you Kip is
synonymous with Nigel Faraj whoever wins
the leadership I think that's certainly
been true and and an absolutely Nigel
was one of the founding members so we're
talking about 25 years ago now but what
I've sensed from the hustings as we've
been traveling around the country doing
the hustings in front of members is
there is a real appetite for change now
I think we recognized that it is time to
move on people are feeling very
optimistic and positive about the future
under a new leader and that's been very
heartening both for me and I know the
other candidates as well yes Nigel is a
huge figure he will have a role to play
going forward but nobody can go on
forever and I'm sure Nigel doesn't want
to cling on to any any position you know
he needs to to change his focus as well
he's obviously doing a lot in the United
States now where the president elect
Trump he's thinking about possibly a
seat in the House of Lords as well so I
get the sense that perhaps Nigel wants
to move on to and certainly our members
are very optimistic about the future
under a new leader which will inevitably
take the party in a slightly different
direction or will have
slightly different change of tone and
therefore a great opportunity to appeal
to a whole new set of voters out there
just want to raise a couple of points
that you mentioned there and the loving
with Donald Trump between knives of Raj
and other members of you have you been
highly critical we even I've talked
about it some of the comments that
Donald Trump made on the campaign trail
do you think they're getting too cozy
well I think actually it's quite good
but that Nigel was out there building
bridges because you know Teresa may have
said some things about Donald Trump that
weren't exactly pleasant either there
was even a vote here and certainly a
debate in Parliament about whether or
not he should be banned from the country
so I was actually pleased to see a
British politician out there building
those bridges mending some fences
actually saying you know Britain's great
and I'm very pleased to hear that I
think Donald Trump is going to be
meeting the Queen fairly shortly too you
know loving will loathe him the fact is
he was democratically elected to be the
next president of the United States of
America and I've been as does anybody
else like my reservations about the
riots and the attack he made on the
democratic process but I just want to
race his own I mean you must remember
you were appalled by some of the
comments he made me was you know tape
saying it that he made about women yet
Nigel fryer says you know I endorse the
fact it was locker room talk he called
him a silverback gorilla well I don't
agree with Nigel's comments you know and
that's a great thing you know about
politics you're allowed to disagree yeah
I think I think President Trump said
some reprehensible things but then again
so did Hillary Clinton and I made it
very clear throughout the course of the
presidential campaign that I would have
found it very very difficult to know
which of them to vote for people have
said to me oh but but Hillary was a
woman shouldn't you have backed her well
no absolutely not not for that reason
alone they say well Hillary had
experience of politics Donald Trump
didn't and I say well that's the point
isn't it Hillary had experience she was
found wanting on the basis of that
experience it was that actually that I
think that that meant she lost I I think
a better woman would have easily beaten
Trump and perhaps you know
a better Republican would would it would
have lost to the Democrats have there
been a different candidate and do you
think the government should use Nigel
Farage's links with Donald Trump maybe
put him in the House of Lords to do that
I think any government has got to put
the best interests of its people first
so that means our government needs to
put the best interests of Britain first
I think brexit is a great precursor to
that we could have a super trade deal
with the United States of America a
bilateral trade deal trumps already
ruled out TTIP this ridiculous European
Union construct which I'm very grateful
that seems to now be well and truly hit
the buffers so I think we have a very
positive relationship ahead with with
with America regardless who's a who's
president you know we have the got that
special relationship it's going to take
some serious malfunction to be able to
destroy that and I think the one good
thing about Trump's presidency is that
he has made it clear he wants to keep
that particularly in terms of trade and
yes you know Nigel Farage may well be
able to support and facilitate that as
I'm sure will many many others of us